>> YOU'RE WATCHING BRAVO.
WHEN DOES YOUR BOYFRIEND GET
BACK IN TOWN?
AT 11:00, IT'S ANDY COHEN'S
ENDOSCOPE CAMP.
COMING UP NEXT -- DO YOU LOVE
OUR PROGRAMMING BUT
DON'T GIVE A "D" ABOUT THE
STORYLINES?
KEEP WATCHING THE NEWEST REALITY
SHOW "THE REAL INTROS OF REALITY
HILLS."
>> TWO'S A CROWD.
THREE'S A PARTY.
SIX OR MORE, HONEY, YOU NEED A
RESERVATION.
>> MY HUSBAND --
MY HUSBAND'S A DOCTOR, AND MY
FACE, ALL SCIENCE.
>> I'M TOO OLD AND MY HAIR IS
TOO LONG.
>> THE SOUTH WILL RISE AGAIN.
BUT WHEN I STAND UP TOO FAST, I
PASS OUT.
>> I HAVE A BABY VOICE BUT MY
HUSBAND'S 100 YEARS OLD.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT THEY SAY,
YOU'RE ONLY AS OLD AS YOUR
CURRENT WIFE.
>> I'M A REAL ESTATE MOGUL WHO
CAN'T READ.
LINE UP, LADIES.
>> HALF JEWISH BUT I'M ALL
WOMAN.
YOU'RE HIRED!
>> I'M AS GAY AS MY TWIN.
>> I'M AS GAY AS MY WIFE.
>> WE HAVE A SKIN CARE LINE
THAT'S HUGE IN IRAQ.
JEALOUS?
>> WE BOILED THESE WOMEN DOWN TO
TWO LINES.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> DON'T EXAMINE MY CHARITY TOO
HARD.
IT'S RACIST.
>> MY SECRET?
I USED TO BE ASIAN.
>> I RESPECT THE SABBATH.
UNLESS THE SABBATH DISRESPECTS
ME.
OY, VEY, YOU'RE FILMING.
>> HIS BOOTY IS REAL.
>> BUT MY PERSONALITY IS FAKE.
>> OUR NIECE PLAYED TOPANGA ON
"BOY MEETS WORLD."
JEALOUS?
>> LET'S FACE IT, WE BARELY HAVE
STORYLINES ANYWAY SO WE CUT TO
THE CHASE.
>> I GIVE MY SON OPEN-MOUTH
KISSES AND I GO TO THIRD WITH MY
DOG.
RELAX, IT'S HIM TO ME.
>> DATING MY SISTER'S FRIENDS,
SLEPT WITH MY MOTHER'S FRIENDS.
NEXT YEAR I'M GOING TO GAIN 150
POUNDS.
THAT'S WHAT'S UP.
>> JESUS WAS JUST A MAN.
>> WE'RE SO CLOSE WE FINISH EACH
OTHER --
>> OFF.
>> THERE'S A PRISON NAMED AFTER
OUR FAMILY.
JEALOUS?
>> YOU HEARD THE TAG LINES.
NOW ALL THAT'S LEFT IS THREE
SECONDS OF DRAMA.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT YOU DID, BITCH.
>> IS THIS WHITE CULTURE?
>> THIS HAS BEEN "THE REAL
INTROS OF REALITY HILLS."